[Musique]
charlemagne et le plus célèbre des
souverains de la dynastie carolingienne
qui lui doit d'ailleurs son nom
conquérant administrateurs législateur
propagateurs de la religion catholique
il agit en maître et défenseurs de
l'église quelqu'un qui réussit à fédérer
toutes les énergies l'effet des énergies
intellectuelles aussi les énergies
administratives pour unifier son royaume
d'une certaine façon l'empiré de
charlemagne tiens par la personne de
charlemagne
l'église fut l'instrument de sa
politique de rénovation culturel
l'orthodoxie religieuse et la culture
était essentiel pour lui il s'est placé
en tant que protecteur des arts et des
lettres et est à l'origine de la
renaissance carolingienne charlemagne
est considéré comme le père de l'europe
puisqu'il a assuré le regroupement de
l'europe occidentale
il a aussi posé des principes de
gouvernement dont ont hérité des grands
états européens
charlemagne est un monarque guerrier il
a agrandi le royaume grâce à une série
de campagnes dans les années 770 il
commença ses nombreuses conquêtes
royaume lombard en 773 conquête de la
saxe de 771 à 804 roncevaux fut l'une de
ses plus grandes défaites
cependant ses ennemis furent
continuellement repoussé ses qualités de
chef de guerre qui sont à la fois
pragmatique et tactique vont de pair
avec une grande cruauté le signe
éclatant de l'autorité acquise par
charlemagne fut son couronnement en tant
qu'empereur par le pape léon iii en 800
l'énorme empire ne peut survivre à la
disparition de son créateur
charlemagne soucieux de la tradition
germanique avait prévu de le partager
entre ses trois fils d 806 mêlant pire
ne fut en fait partager qu'entre ces
trois petits fils lors du traité de
verdun en 843
[Musique]
la date de naissance de charlemagne est
difficile à déterminer car il existe
très peu de documents d'époque charles
premier dit charles le grand ou
charlemagne en latin carolus magnus
serait né le 2 avril 742 ou 748 selon
les sources
le père anselme historien et
généalogiste français du xviie siècle
avant cela date 742 en reprenant le
témoignage de et dinard qui était un
écrivain contemporain et biographe de
charlemagne l'écrit que charlemagne
avait 72 ans lors de son décès en 814
danse habitat caroline mani la vie de
charlemagne
cet ouvrage est l'une des sources
principales pour connaître le roi
charlemagne son règne et ses
réalisations
la naissance de charlemagne reste
quelque chose d'important puisque il
inaugure un règne extrêmement long l'un
des plus longs de l'histoire de france
presque aussi long que celui de louis
xiv
nous ne pouvons absolument pas connaître
le lieu de naissance de ce jeune
souverain étant donné qu'il a dû
probablement naître dans un domaine
rural du nord de la gaule appartenant à
la famille carolingienne ils ne sont pas
plus étant donné que les détails
manquent absolument sur cette question
le lieu de naissance de charlemagne est
ignorée et guinard lui même passe
volontairement sous silence ce qui a
rapport à la première partie de la vie
de charlemagne
il est possible de présumer qu'il vit le
jour entre la meuse et le rhin grâce aux
récits sur la fondation de l'église
d'aix la chapelle
charlemagne le fils de pépin le bref et
de berthe de l'an
dit berthe aux grands pieds fille du
comte de l'an un puissant seigneur de
l'époque
quant à pépin le bref frère de griffon
et car le mans
il est le fils de charles martel duc
d'austrasie et maire du palais et dirt
rude
lorsque pépin le bref décède le 24
septembre 768 en respect de la tradition
franco matière de succession ses deux
fils car le mans et charles sont élus
roi le 9 octobre 768 par une assemblée
populaire lors de la mort du grand-père
de charlemagne charles martel perdent
pépin le bref carloman et griffon le
royaume avait déjà été partagé entre ses
trois fils l'aîné car le mans devint
maire du palais d'austrasie et obtient
l'allemagne et la thuringe pépin lui
devint maire du palais de neustrie avec
la provence et la bourgogne griffon
n'obtient que quelques comtés c'est
l'époque de la fin de la dynastie
mérovingienne
serwa que l'on qualifiera plus tard de
fainéants ont perdu leur autorité et les
maires du palais dirige l'état estimé
romain vienne est un processus
relativement lent c'est à dire que le
monde mérovingiens à antran lente
décadence à partir du milieu du 7e
siècle mais les rois du début du viiie
siècle sont encore des rois tonique qui
sont capables d'administrer la justice
de façon efficace de contrôler la
richesse publique voir de temps en temps
de condamner leur maire du palais pour
entrave aux forces de l'ordre
donc de temps en temps les derniers
mérovingiens ont condamné les ancêtres
de charlemagne pour fraude
mais à partir de charles martel c'est à
dire à partir surtout les année 730 la
dynastie mérovingienne et condamné par
une série de succession très rapide des
rois jeunes qui ne parviennent pas à
tenir le pouvoir et rapidement les
maires du palais de la famille des pipis
need contrôler les derniers bastions la
puissance pure aurasienne c'est à dire
la richesse publique l'église et à
partir des à 1740 on peut dire
finalement que la dynastie mérovingienne
et étape pépin le bref après le choix de
la vie monastique par son frère car le
mans cherche à obtenir l'appui de
l'église et de l'aristocratie il fait
remarquer au peuple accary clairoix
n'exerce plus leur pouvoir dans le
royaume et lui demande si c'est un mal
ou un bien
vous avez une réponse du pape la carie
kilic en effet vaudrait mieux petit
frère le roi ce soit celui qui a le
pouvoir
751 il devint le seul dirigeant du
royaume franc et obtint du pape accary
l'autorisation de mettre fin au règne
des mérovingiens et de prendre la
couronne de childéric 3 pour devenir roi
des francs à soissons en se faisant
acclamer par les grands du royaume le
pape sacre le père pépin et le fils à
saint denis en 754 en échange pépin
s'est engagé à défendre les territoires
du pape en italie face aux anciens
propriétaires lombard le 9 octobre 768
le partage est tel que charlemagne se
voit attribuer la partie de son père
pépin le bref et se fait sacrer roi à
noyon alors que car le mans obtient
celle de laurent khl car le mans et
siège à soissons les premières
difficultés apparaissent entre les deux
frères qui ne s'entendent pas les
partager tant leur premier souci
en 769 le duc d'aquitaine se révoltent
et affiche des velléités d'indépendance
charlemagne demande de l'aide à son
frère qui va lui est refusé et se
retrouve seul pour rétablir l'ordre
il y parvient en menaçant les gascons
c'est à dire les basques qui lui livre
finalement le duc rebelles en 770 c'est
la lombardie qui apparaît menaçante
berthe de lance amer arrange un mariage
entre charles et désiré la fille du roi
des lombards elle fut répudier en 771
par charlemagne officiellement pour
cause de stérilité
mais il est avancé que c'était parce
qu'il n'aimait pas son physique en 771
carloman décède au palais de sam aussi
près de laon le lendemain de sa mort
charles destitue l'héritage de ses
neveux qui s'enfuit avec gerber ge
la femme de carloman vers la cour
lombarde accompagné de quelques
partisans
charles est à leur souverain de tout le
royaume franc
[Musique]
depuis l'époque de clovis les francs
même des grandes conquêtes des concrètes
qui vont essentiellement vers l'est
conquête d'abord dû royaume à l'amant
c'est-à-dire de l'alsace actuelle
conquête ensuite de la thuringe conquête
de quelques marges de la saxe conquête
du royaume frison c'est à dire des pays
bas actuels puis petit à petit le
royaume mérovingiens est allé jusqu'en
bavière charlemagne va reprendre cette
grande tradition d'extension vers l'est
en essayant de s'emparer de toute la
saxe c'est à dire de toute l'allemagne
continental actuelle jusqu'aux
frontières du danemark et des conquêtes
également qu'il va mener vers l'italie
pour venir au secours des papes le
pouvoir carolingien va s'emparer de
l'italie et détruire le royaume lombard
c'est la guerre qui peut amener la
richesse surtout depuis que les liens
commerciaux avec byzance sont plus
difficiles pour assurer sa pérennité
une puissance doit s'étendre c'est
pourquoi charles martel et pépin le bref
avait repris à l'église une grande
partie de ses terres afin de les
distribuer à leurs vassaux les vassaux
étaient des hommes libres qui était
devenu dépendant de leur seigneur par la
cérémonie de l'hommage le seigneur doit
les entretenir avec des dons afin de
conserver leur fidélité et les vassaux
deviennent des guerriers qui défendent
leur seigneur
depuis des générations les pépines id
étendre leur domination clip i need est
le nom donné aux membres de la dynastie
de la noblette franck d'austrasie dont
plusieurs se nomme pépin
les comptes sont enrichis ce grâce à ces
guerres et donne des terres leurs
vassaux pour garantir leur fidélité
cela permet à charlemagne d'être à la
tête d'une des armées les plus
importantes en occident à l'image de ses
prédécesseurs
les historiens estiment que l'armée de
charlemagne était composé de dix mille à
40000 guerrier 17173 charles tentent de
conquérir le royaume lombardie italie
les relations entre didier leroy des
lombards et le jeune roi franc se
dégrade très vite
charles avait répudier sa fille le pape
adrien premier se réjouit de cette
opportunité comme l'avait fait son
prédécesseur il demande de l'aide auprès
du roi franc en effet la papauté et
toujours sous la tutelle de l' empire
byzantin qui possèdent encore des
territoires autour de rome mais les
byzantins n'ont plus les moyens de
protéger rome contre les lombards trop
occupés par leur lutte contre l' empire
musulman
le nouveau souverain pontife est un
noble romain pieux et cultivé il est
hostile aux lombards et se montre
inflexible
contrairement à certains de ses
prédécesseurs il renvoie immédiatement
la première ambassade de leur roi didier
qui lâche alors ses troupes sur les
territoires dont charles était le gars
charles un grand intérêt à soumettre les
lombards menace constante
d'autant que le roi didier veut
réhabiliter les fils de car le mans
réfugiés à sa cour charlot traverse
alors les alpes avec son armée qui se
divisent en deux groupes afin de
faciliter le passage des montagnes
l'intérêt de cette division est aussi
stratégique afin de prendre les lombards
en tenant une surprise les attend
cependant en bas des montagnes un mur a
été érigé pour bloquer l'accès à la
vallée le roi franc envoie donc la
cavalerie légère et défait les lombards
qui pris à revers se réfugie dans la
ville de pavie capitale du royaume
la ville est imprenable et charlemagne
choisit donc de laisser agir la fin au
printemps 774 pavie n'a toujours pas
capituler et charles décide de célébrer
les fêtes de pâques à rome c'est la
première fois qu'il se rend dans la
ville sainte
il promet au pape que lorsqu'il rentrera
dans ta vie il cédera des terres aux
états pontificaux dans les annales
pontificale c'est à ce moment que
charles devint carolus magnus
c'est à dire charlemagne deux mois plus
tard la ville de pavie tombe enfin
charles prow talent le titre de roi des
francs et des lombards en 774 la
capitale du royaume lombard pavie tombe
mais finalement c'est une longue
histoire puisque la capitale de pavie
avait déjà été assiégé à fin du 6e
siècle par les mérovingiens
c'est à dire que charlemagne entre dans
la pure continuité de ses prédécesseurs
il fait alors son entrée triomphale dans
la capitale coiffé de la célèbre
couronne de fer dont le fermoir selon la
légende a été forgée avec un clou de la
vraie croix du christ
la campagne lombarde avait été difficile
avec de nombreuses révoltes et une forte
répression l'armée carolingienne
s'appuyer donc sur une tactique dans
laquelle la cavalerie joué un rôle
fondamental
qu'elles soient lourdes est paré pour
les chocs frontaux ou qu'elles soient
légères et extrêmement mobiles
la chevalerie de charlemagne et est
élaborée afin de répondre à toutes les
éventualités
les guerres de saxe commencèrent 17 172
tout au long de son règne les
difficultés les plus conséquentes auquel
charles devra faire face sont liées au
sax c'était un peuples païens de
barbares que ni les penny l'appel de
l'évangile ne semblait convaincre il
vivait sur des territoires devenus
aujourd'hui les flandres et la lorraine
en plus de leur terre d'origine la saxe
l'allemagne actuelle charlemagne pensait
que les frontières du royaume ne serait
pas en sécurité tant que les saxons
serait de taille 1 les saxons qui avait
promis des concessions
profitèrent de la campagne de lombardie
pour se révolter charlemagne décide de
les soumettre par la force et instaure
la loi du fer de dieu qui consiste à
imposer aux peuples conquis le choix
entre le baptême ou la mort après
plusieurs années d'alternance entre
combat reddition et révolte les saxons
sont de nouveau battu et promettre leur
conversion au christianisme charlemagne
rentrer avec son lot d'otages saxe en
début d année 780 les intraitables
saxons se soulève de nouveau il entre en
territoire franc et provoque des ravages
jusqu'à la moselle charlemagne organise
donc une sévère répression mais les
révoltes n'en continue pas moins comme
on dépeint filou kind les saxons oppose
une vigoureuse résistance vide ou kind
fut en effet l'un des plus obstinée
opposant la christianisation de son
peuple
ce qui fait également de lui l'un des
principaux adversaires que charlemagne
rencontrera durant ses campagnes pour
étendre le royaume des francs en 782 une
partie de l'aristocratie saxon est prête
à intégrer le royaume franc et ainsi
conforter sa position sociale mais
charlemagne doit faire face cette même
année à une grande révolte l'armée
franck se fait dépasser par le peuple
qui vit en ordre dispersé sur un
territoire immense au relief vallonné
face à cette révolte les francs vont
commettre des atrocités afin d'affirmer
leur domination
le massacre de verdun fera 4500 victimes
et douze mille femmes et enfants sont
déportés car il refuse le baptême
charles se conduisit alors comme le
fléau de dieu usant de la politique de
la terre brûlée renversant leur idole
ravageant leurs sanctuaires massacrant
et pillant tout sur son passage
soit il saisit c'est les chefs des
tribus révolter et les faisait décapité
sur le front des taupes soit il faisait
plonger des clans entier dans un fleuve
il reprenait en pays saxons une méthode
autrefois utilisée par son grand père
puis par son père le chef des saxons
ville où kind se réfugier chez ses
voisins et ceux mis sous la protection
de zekri d' roi des danois après cette
victoire
charlemagne réorganise la saxe qui
devient une province de son empire et
ordonne la conversion forcée des saxons
payen la plupart des rebelles ont été
livrés à charlemagne par les chefs
saxons sauf vide au kindle introuvable
celui ci obtient le soutien des frisons
et des danois établi au nord de l'helpe
les france ont battu par bee doo kind au
mons une tonne en 782 s'ils sont
victorieux l'année suivante ils doivent
gouverner dans le pays 2 784 à 785 pour
venir à bout du soulèvement en 785
charlemagne instaurant saxe le
capitulaire de party bus saxonia les
païens doivent se convertir sous peine
de condamnation à mort vie du king
aurait accepté de se rendre contre la
promesse de ne pas être tués
voyant qu'il a gagné son soutien
charlemagne le persuade de se faire
baptiser lors d'une cérémonie collective
en 785 à attigny dans les ardennes dans
les années 792 à 795 des saxons se
soulève à nouveau
refusant le capitulaire les rebelles
saxons demande l'aide des frisons leurs
voisins du nord
eux aussi païens et des avares déjà en
lutte contre charlemagne
il réhabilite le culte des idoles pis
les églises et traquent les catholiques
devant la tournure que prennent les
événements charlemagne doivent revenir
en saxe
il dévisse son armée en deux une partie
sous ses ordres
l'autre sous ceux de son fils charles le
jeune charlemagne entre en thuringe et
charles en vespa ni les rebelles se
rendent sans combat et jurent fidélité
aux voix l'année suivante
charlemagne et son armée traverse la
saxe jusqu'à l'elbe si la pacification
de la saxe durera encore plusieurs
années
elle s'achève officiellement atteint
d'airbourne en 799 en 711 les mort
envahisse l'espagne sous le commandement
de tarik ibn zyad il imposa une grande
partie de l'espagne et du portugal
le renne islamique ils étendent leur
influence et font des incursions jusque
dans le nord de la france mais sont
arrêtés à la bataille de toulouse en 721
et par charles martel à la bataille de
poitiers en 732 dans la péninsule
ibérique
seul le nord-ouest et les régions
majoritairement basques des pyrénées
échappent à leur domination pour le pape
comme tous les chrétiens il revient à
charlemagne de se défendre contre ce
danger permanent
charlemagne n'avait pas l'intention de
conquérir l'espagne il avait conscience
du décalage économique et culturelle des
deux mondes
de plus il admire la civilisation
islamique très avancés sur le commerce
l'artisanat les sciences et les arts
souleymane sy ben al arabi ou ali c'est
à dire gouverneur de barcelone et gérone
et menacé par l'émir abd al-rahman de
cordes
il envoie donc une délégation à
charlemagne afin de lui offrir sa
soumission et l'allégeance de hussein de
saragosse le gouverneur de la ville en
échange d'une aide militaire
l'occasion était belle pour carolus
magnus d'affermir sa réputation en
faisant une démonstration de la
puissance de son armée intimider les
musulmans et rasséréné les chrétiens
soumis à leurs autorités
voilà deux objectifs exaltant pour le
protecteur du pape
en réponse l'armée de charlemagne
traverse les pyrénées vers saragosse en
778 dans le but de tenir là il s'entoure
de 12 duc et chaque duc dispose de trois
mille cavaliers hussein de saragosse
refuse d'ouvrir les portes de la ville
déclarant qu'il n'avait jamais promis
son allégeance trouvant les portes
closes
l'armée du roi franc décide de retourner
dans son royaume
400 machines de siège qu'il ne pouvait
pas transporter à cause des pyrénées la
cavalerie et inefficace
sur le chemin du retour l'armée met à
sac la ville basque de pampelune qui
avaient pourtant résisté à la pression
musulmane puis en août 778 une partie de
l'armée doit se replier pour rejoindre
la germanie car les saxons s'était de
nouveau révélée ce groupe est composé de
charlemagne et de son escorte
l'armée est divisée en deux car le
passage est très étroit l'arrière-garde
qui protège le repli s'engage ensuite
dans les vallées pyrénéennes
elle est commandée par roland gouverneur
de la marche de bretagne à valeureux
guerriers présumé de charlemagne
il passe par le col de roncevaux située
à une cinquantaine de kilomètres de pont
plus ce qu elle correspond à l'ancien
passage axial du bagne état à 1066
mètres d'altitude voie de passage
naturel utilisé depuis la préhistoire
pour accéder à la péninsule ibérique sur
les pentes escarpées de concevons les
vascons ancêtres des gascons et des
basques attaque par surprise en
représailles du pillage de pampelune il
dévale les montagnes et massacrent la
troupe franck surprenant l'ennemi sur
les hauteurs afin de les précipiter dans
le rab roland parmi d'autres serviteurs
du roi tombe il n'y a pas eu de combats
ce fut une exécution cet événement
devint le fait d'armes le plus connu du
règne grâce à un grand poème épique et
une chanson de geste écrit à la fin du
xième siècle la chanson de rolland alors
qu'est guinard dans vita carolis magli
accuse les vascons de ce revers la
chanson de roland évoque les sarrasins
terme qui englobe tous les musulmans et
fait de roland un martyr chrétien
la plupart des historiens s'accordent
maintenant pour dire qu'à la bataille de
roncevaux les carolingiens ont en fait
affronter la milice basque et non
l'armée sarrasine
en pleine période de reconquête de
l'europe et de conquête en orient il est
fort possible que le texte de la chanson
de rolland était écrit pour donner un
fondement historique aux croisades et
transformer une guerre territoriale en
guerre sainte
charlemagne se contenta des lords
occuper des places fortes en catalogne
les représailles sont impossibles
comment manoeuvrer dans ce dédale de
pierre et qui punit le soulèvement des
saxons encouragea par ailleurs le duc de
bavière à sion 3 qui en 779 refusa de
reconnaître la souveraineté franck et
fut sur le point de semer le trouble
dans toute la partie sud de la germanie
occupée par les francs ah si l'on était
le fils deal trudeau fils naturel de
charles martel et pousse du duc odile
ans de bavière ce lien de parenté avait
permis à sa mère d'être régente du duché
de bavière pour son compte en 748 en 750
cette date ils ont juré fidélité au roi
des francs à l'assemblée de compiègne
devenant ainsi le vassal de pépin le
bref en 787 a si longtemps à d'obtenir
le soutien du pape adrien 1er mai la
faveur de l'église allait offrant
charlemagne son cousin leva trois armées
pour soumettre le duc rebelles
tu as ils ont contraint et forcé
renouvela son serment ou les chsld près
dans ce bourg le 3 octobre 787
de retour dans sa capitale à ratisbonne
tassilo repris ses intrigues
il négociait notamment avec les avares
ennemis des francs mais le parti de
l'aristocratie qui était favorable à
charles fille prévenir ce dernier cas si
l'on fut forcé d'avouer tous les crimes
qu'on voulait bien lui reconnaître et
fut condamné à mort en 788
toutefois en raison de son lien de
parenté charles le fils au v mais à
condition qu'il entre dans les ordres
ce qu'il fit à l'abbaye saint-pierre de
jumièges ayant supprimé la fonction de
duke et l'ayant remplacée par la charge
de plusieurs comptes charlemagne mate
les bavarois rebelles et met à la tête
de l'armée un préfère la personne de son
beau frère
gerold la bavière est ainsi intégrée au
royaume en 788 charlemagne confisqué les
biens immense de tess ils ont qui était
considéré comme l'homme le plus riche de
lempire plus que charlemagne lui même
qui de surcroît n'a jamais eu de fortune
personnelle et fut un des premiers rois
de l'époque médiévale à distinguer le
trésor royal et ses biens propres
après la bavière en 791 avec l'aide de
son fils pépin d'italie
charles mène contre les avares une
première expédition
les averses ont une peuplade belliqueuse
d'origine mongole comme les uns et les
slaves
ils sont établis en pannonie l'actuel
hongrie les avares pillards payen
constitue pour les fronts une menace
constante
ils ont multiplié les incursions
dévastatrices en balles hier et dans le
frioul en 788 il s'attaque aux églises
qu'ils pillent sans vergogne et met à
l'abri leurs trésors dans un camp
fortifié fortement gardée appelé le ring
la guerre contre les avares et sans
pitié charlemagne répond à la férocité
de l'ennemi par une férocité égal pour
la première campagne en 791 charlemagne
fait appel à dix mille cavaliers et pour
faire suivre l'intendance nécessaire un
train de bateaux progressent en même
temps sur le danube charlemagne divise
son armée en deux afin d'avancer en même
temps sur les deux rives du danube
il confie le commandement de sel au nord
aux comptes théorique alors qu'une
troisième force mené par son fils pépin
doit attaquer à revers depuis la
frontière du frioul l'armée franck en 30
r av ar à la fin du mois de septembre
sans rencontrer de résistance
les avares pratiquer la politique de la
terre brûlée
ainsi à la mi octobre alors que charles
atteint la rivière raab le manque de
fourrage et les privations imposées aux
soldats le décide à faire demi tour sans
avoir livré bataille charlemagne ne
renonce pas et en 793 il prépare de
nouveau la guerre contre les amarres il
fait construire un pont de bateaux
démontable sur le danube et commence la
construction d'un canal pour relier les
bassins du rhin et du danube
néanmoins ce projet n'aboutira pas cette
même année l'armée que charlemagne lève
en frise contre les avares et détruites
aarhus triengen dans les sacs sont
révoltés lecomte théodoric et tué et la
révolte de la saxe ajourne l'expédition
contre les amarres en 795
l'affrontement se termine par la prise
du camp retranché royal avare par pépin
il envahit le pays avec des forces
considérables
le camp abrite un trésor gigantesque
fruit de plusieurs années de pillage
le territoire havard est placée sous le
contrôle des francs puis christianisée
la prise du butin du ring à barr quinze
chars d'or fut envoyé à aix et joue un
rôle conséquent dans la puissance de
charlemagne lui permettant de
récompenser largement ses fidèles on
estime que ce seul butin a contribué à
un mouvement d' inflation sensible dans
l'ensemble de
pire carolingien les relations entre
charlemagne et le pape
adrien premier n'était pas si exemplaire
la toscane et toute l'italie du sud
était promise au pape
mais le souverain francs préféré imposer
sa propre domination sur l'italie
l'indépendance des états du pape était
de plus en plus fictive
malgré tout charles est soucieux de sa
construction politique et il sait que le
facteur religieux est essentielle aussi
lorsque le nouveau pape léon iii est
emprisonné en 799 et roué de coups par
des nobles qui l'accusent d'immoralité
charlemagne intervient et assure le
retour du pape à rome sous bonne escorte
un nouveau voyage à rome et décide un an
et demi plus tard en décembre 800 et
après quelques interventions chez les
saxons charlemagne vient soutenir le
pape dans ses fonctions selon les
lettrés de l'époque comme al q1
le prince idéal doit avoir un but
religieux et lutter contre les
hérétiques et les païens y compris hors
des frontières halkin et d'autres
écrivains constate que l' empire
d'orient l' empire byzantin est tombé
aux mains d'une femme donc il n'ya plus
d'emploi roma que lé roi des francs sont
les seules qui existent comme souverain
réellement important en occident il faut
donc rétablir lempire en occident en la
personne de charlemagne charlemagne et
roi des francs des lombards et à travers
les conquêtes le royaume ne cesse de
s'étendre
non seulement vous avez un roi qui roide
plusieurs royaumes mais vous avez des
rois qui sont les sous vont redonner à
roye sable ça ne va plus la notion royal
est en train de de perdre son sens de
perdre sa substance et on risque
l'éclatement
il doit devenir empereur d'occident afin
d'avoir une autorité légitime sur
l'ensemble des peuples qu'ils gouvernent
charlemagne désire créer l'empiré
carolingien un empire pluriethnique
civilisateur le pape léon iii va dans ce
sens
mais pour lui le pouvoir spirituel
l'emportent sur le pouvoir temporel et
il sera le signifier clairement au futur
empereur le jour de noël de l'an 800
charlemagne est couronné empereur
d'occident par le pape léon iii à la
basilique saint pierre de rome
la papauté doit énormément à charlemagne
puisque celui ci a renforcé les états
pontificaux créée par son père mais pas
de brefs et qu'en même temps à la suite
d'une émeute il a libéré le pape et que
celui-ci du coup l'a remercié en le
couronner empereur le 25 décembre de
l'ennui semble cependant les rites du
couronnement vont être inversé au profit
du pape le pape pose la couronne sur la
tête de l'empereur charlemagne en le
faisant acclamer par ses troupes
mais il fait exprès de le faire un clamé
après avoir déposé la couronne sur la
tête de charlemagne ce qui veut dire que
le pouvoir spirituel est supérieur au
pouvoir temporel et que charlemagne ne
doit pas lempire à ces victoires qui
pourtant sont importantes mais qu'il le
doit à une désignation particulière par
dieu nous sommes dans un système de
chrétienté
selon hugues inard le biographe de
charlemagne l'empereur est sorti furieux
de la cérémonie il aurait préféré que
l'on suive le rituel byzantin c'est à
dire l'acclamation le couronnement et
enfin l'adoration l'empiré byzantin
refuse de reconnaître le couronnement
impérial le considérant comme une
usurpation charles et ses conseillers
havok le fait que l' empire d'orient ne
peut être dirigée que par un homme or
c'est à l'époque une femme
l'impératrice irène de byzance qui
revendique ce titre ce n'est qu'avec le
traité de paix d'aix-la-chapelle en 812
que michel premier rang jab et à leur
empereur d'orient dagne accepté vraiment
de reconnaître le titre impérial de
charlemagne et de ses successeurs en
utilisant toutefois des formules
détourné évitant de se prononcer sur la
légitimité du titre un tel que charleroi
des francs que l'on appelle leur
empereur le souverain ce titre lui-même
empereur gouvernants l' empire romain
roi des francs et des lombards
[Musique]
au viiie siècle les carolingiens
originaire d'australie déplace vers le
nord-est leur résidence au début de son
règne
charlemagne n'a pas de lieu de résidence
fixe il se déplace avec sa cour de villa
en villa comme celle de metz ou de
thionville il ne peut de toute façon
s'établir à rome car c'est la ville du
pape des états pontificaux
il décide donc de s'implanter dans
l'ancienne austrasie la terre de ses
ancêtres à partir de 790 l'empereur
réside le plus souvent à aix-la-chapelle
aix la chapelle à la fin du viiie siècle
n'avait rien d'une capitale c'était une
station thermale antique fondée par les
romains solo et guinard charlemagne la
découverte lors d'une partie de chasse
ils apprécient l'endroit et ont fait son
lieu de résidence et la capitale de
lempire construisant un palais dont la
magnifique chapelle allait devenir la
cathédrale le palais de charlemagne fut
construit sous ses ordres
son architecture s'inspire des
traditions romaine et byzantine
charlemagne ya résidé de 801 à sa mort
en 814 et y est enterré
la situation géographique d'aix la
chapelle dans le royaume carolingien est
un atout pour la ville
le nouveau royaume franc et résolument
axé sur le rhin
l'acce rome aix la chapelle est l'épiné
dorsale de l'occident chrétien sous
charlemagne et louis le pieux la ville
d'aix se développe grâce au palais la
justice royale se rend dans la salle de
juridiction du palais il abrite aussi
une caserne militaire et un atelier
monétaire charlemagne fedex la chapelle
le siège de sa cour
ainsi la ville devient aussi une
capitale intellectuelle
elle est considérée comme la nouvelle
athènes charlemagne créé l'académie
palatine un cercle de l'est très réservé
aux beaux esprits proches de l'empereur
qui a pour mission de former la nouvelle
génération de comptes d'administrateurs
sachant lire et écrire
elle dispose aussi d'une importante
bibliothèque la cour la demeure de
charlemagne et est aussi le lieu de
réception des ambassadeurs on sait que
charlemagne avait voulu rivaliser avec
le palais de constantinople
cela se ressent d'abord dans les
dimensions de l'édifice
c'est un rectangle au sol de 180 m le
palais d'aix était deux fois moins
étendu que celui des empereurs byzantins
la salle royale comportait trois absides
dont l'une abritait le siège impérial à
l'ouest comme les basiliques romaines la
hauteur de la salle royale est aussi
majestueuse 20 m deux rangées de
fenêtres assurait une luminosité
parfaite
cette construction témoignent des
richesses de charlemagne et mais aussi
de la volonté d'originalité de
l'empereur ex avait un plan général tout
à fait nouveau avec une ordonnance
extérieur et un aspect intérieur
originaux la chapelle est un témoin de
la renaissance carolingienne la salle
voûtée annonce les cathédrales la
décoration des grilles par des hélices
marguerite 13 cordelette entre la est
typiquement carolingienne cet art de
cour originale a eu un rayonnement dans
tout le royaume carolingien car les
prélats et les palatins voulurent timité
l'empereur au début du neuvième siècle
l'état francs représente déjà un vaste
empire et ses frontières sont fortement
consolidé après le couronnement de
charlemagne le centre de gravité de
lempire se déplace vers l'est c'est à
dire au détriment de la france
au bénéfice de l'allemagne à cette
époque il y a trois empires rivaux
l'empiré carolingien l'empiré byzantin
[Musique]
et l'empiré arabe
ce nouveau monde en raison de
l'antagonisme religieux ne peut pas
tirer profit des relations maritimes
entre l'orient et l'occident
contrairement au monde romain dollars
structuration de lempire franc qui
s'oriente vers une activité économique
située entre le rhin et la meuse
favorisant la future allemagne en raison
d'un commerce déficitaire avec le monde
musulman et de la diminution des
échanges avec le monde méditerranéen due
à la perte de contrôle de la
méditerranée par byzance
la diminution du numéraire en or rend
nécessaire l'adoption d'une monnaie
frappée avec un minerai plus abondant en
europe que l'or charlemagne institut
parent capitulaire en 794 un système
basé sur l'argent
il se fonde sur les monnaies de l'
empire romain
cette uniformisation de la monnaie
facilite les transactions commerciales à
travers l' empire et donc augmente les
échanges entre les différentes régions
une véritable révolution économique est
lancé
l'utilisation de la monnaie s'accélère
et est attestée même pour des échanges
modestes en homogénéisant la monnaie
d'argent charlemagne a réalisé une
grande avancée à l'époque sans la
monnaie
le paysan de produits que pour survivre
et pour le versement de la redevance à
son seigneur
alors que si la monnaie se développe il
peut vendre le surplus de sa production
et améliorer ses conditions de vie
l'empereur a le monopole pour battre la
monnaie grâce à des ateliers de frappe
qui sont homogénéiser et le souhaitera
paix de son monogramme les carolingiens
ont aussi pris d'autres mesures pour
favoriser le commerce
ils entretiennent les routes et favorise
les foires
néanmoins ce commerce est fortement
encadrée car les prix sont fixés depuis
794 et l'exportation d'armes prohibées
le commerce est aussi fortement axée
puisque le but initial de cette activité
et d'avoir accès à des produits précieux
afin d'entretenir les vassaux suivant
l'usagé des franges charlemagne divise
son empire en compte et il y en a plus
de 200 dans l' empire l'empereur leurs
rangs périodiquement visiter reçoit
alors des représentants de la population
et les chefs du clergé
il contrôle les comptes décide des
travaux à entreprendre dans chaque comté
il tient régulièrement des assemblées
provinciales ou plaident qu'ils tiennent
lieu de cour de justice les juges ou
échevins règle les affaires ordinaires
mais les jugements les plus importants
sont prononcés par le conte ou par le
tribunal royal les comptes et marc qui
sont les vassaux de l'empereur afin de
centraliser son pouvoir
charlemagne réunit des plaies janeiro
dans ces réunions on débattait de tous
les problèmes de l' empire et on
instaurait des lois les fonctionnaires
de lempire les transcrivait ensuite de
façon ordonnée en divisant le texte en
chapitres revêtue de la signature et du
sceau de charlemagne
ces chapitres ou capitulaire était
répandu dans les provinces pourraient
être appliquées charlemagne tente ainsi
de remplacer les traditionnels décision
orale par des écrits avant huit sont
charlemagne avait rédigé 9 capitulaire
après 847 sa priorité et l'uniformité
autour d'une même foi d'une même morale
d'une même culture pour tous et tous ont
juré fidélité à carolus magnus néanmoins
charlemagne ne peut pas toujours
contrôler la manière dans ses ordres
sont appliquées il confie donc cette
charge à des personnes qui sont les yeux
les oreilles et la langue du souverain
ce sont les missi dominici envoyés du
seigneur du maître ils sont instituées
en 789 est renouvelée en lui
2 après le couronnement de 800 les mici
sont la manifestation d'un pouvoir
central au sein de l'empiré d'occident
est l'instrument de sa mise en ordre que
j'aime le bail évolué et s'entourer
d'une élite c'est certain il a voulu
aussi et c'est peut-être une des raisons
pour lesquelles il est si attaché à la
solution et pas seulement à l'école du
ballet il a voulu que ce délit politique
seul capable de gouverner à distance
déjà pour une fois par an lors bidal
parlant de la bonne parole puis
fonctions qu'ils veulent pas du tout
missi dominici
c'est à dire qu'on leur ment les 9
meilleurs généraux pour voir comment ça
se passe et les mici toujours à deux
parfois plus mais au mois deux à
l'évêque et un compte bien l'avouer les
deux c'est plus cher le mandat militaire
us plus dire allez là les devises et
comprendre comment donner ordre comme on
prépare la convocation à l'armée à
partir de 800 les campagnes militaires
est en plus rares le modèle économique
framboise et sur la guerre est de moins
en moins viable il repose sur une
main-d'oeuvre alternativement
combattante ou servile où l'agriculture
est encore largement inspiré du modèle
antique esclavagiste
charlemagne va entreprendre la
restructuration de la société agricole
qui ne se concrétisera cependant pas
avant la révolution agricole de l'an mil
en effet les esclaves ont une faible
productivité n'étant pas intéressé aux
résultats de leur travail
de plus ils sont coûteux lorsqu'il n'y a
pas de guerre les guerres se déroulent
souvent entre mai et octobre comme en
période de paix nombreux sont les
esclaves qui choisissent le travail de
la terre plus rentable des confits leur
sécurité un protecteur ils deviennent
exploitants pour le compte de ce dernier
les esclaves sont donc émancipé en serre
ils dépendent d'un seigneur auxquels ils
versent une redevance et devienne plus
rentable
cette évolution est bien vue par
l'église qui condamne l'esclavagisme
entre chrétiens les les traits du temps
utilise le terme renovatio pour
qualifier le mouvement de renouveau en
occident après deux siècles de déclin
des 774 charlemagne en vainquant les
lombards prend le contrôle de l'italie
du nord et de son précieux patrimoine
culturel
[Musique]
de plus la chute du royaume wisigothe
lors de l'invasion de l'espagne par les
sarrasins à même de nombreux
intellectuels et ecclésiastiques à
rejoindre la cour des rois francs les
carolingiens bénéficie donc de
connaissances venus du royaume qui se
voulait l'héritier de l'empiré romain et
le conservateur de sa culture
depuis le 6e siècle le monachisme est
très fortement développé dans les îles
britanniques
les monastères irlandais conserve les
connaissances latine et grecque et sont
le siège d'une vie intellectuelle
intense les invasions conduite par les
vikings font venir des îles britanniques
des érudits qui contribue avec
l'instauration de la règle de saint
benoît d'aniane à l'essor de la vie
monastique dans le royaume carolingien
cette poussée monastique et la
facilitation de l'écriture aboutissent à
un meilleur partage des connaissances
ainsi de nombreux érudits de toute
l'europe viennent à la cour de
charlemagne et en y partageant leurs
connaissances déclenché la renaissance
carolingienne halkin par exemple est
arrivée d'angleterre en 782 il est l'un
des principaux conseillers de l'empereur
il participe activement au renouveau
biblique la bible daltrey est l'un des
plus anciens manuscrits d'occident il
institue à aix-la-chapelle une école
palatine pour former les futures élites
laïques et religieuses il met en place
un vaste programme d'éducation le
monachisme irlandais et l'instauration
de la règle de saint benoît conduit à la
création de nombreux monastères et
écoles dans tout l'empiré ses monastères
avec leurs deux écoles intérieur et
extérieur leur bibliothèque et leur
scriptorium sont la base de la
renaissance carolingienne charlemagne
prévoit dans son capitulaire admission
généralise de 789 que dans chaque évêché
dans chaque monastère
on enseigne les psaumes les notes les
champs le comput la grammaire et que
l'on est des livres soigneusement
corriger
le nombre d'écoles augmente encore après
le concile de mayence 2 813 qui ordonne
la création d'écoles rurales pour former
de jeunes prêtres nauroy utilisent les
évêques et les abbés comme un personnel
politique expérimenté pour transmettre
et exécuter ses ordres les charges
ecclésiastiques sont pleinement
assimilés aux charges publiques et sont
considérés comme des bénéfices les
propriétés de l'église largement doté
par le roi font partie du bien public
au même titre que le fisc royal l'église
doit subvenir à l'occasion aux besoins
du souverain sous la forme de dons
obligatoire vers 770 la mise au point
par des scripts de l'abbaye de corbis
d'une nouvelle écriture la minuscule
caroline permet de gagner en lisibilité
car les mots sont séparés les uns des
autres et les lettres sont mieux formés
des ateliers de copies se développe dans
les abbayes carolingienne et les
connaissances s'échange dans toute
l'europe pour stimuler et maintenir les
valeurs chrétiennes au sein de son
empire charlemagne adopte donc une
politique culturelle ambitieuse l'art
des manuscrits s'enrichit
considérablement avec les enluminures
mais surtout la minuscule caroline
en effet charles man développe
l'utilisation de l'écrit comme moyen de
diffusion de la connaissance et de l'
usage de la langue latine
s'appuyant sur les érudits britannique
comme al q1 le latin médiéval
s'uniformise et incorpore des mots
nouveaux
avec des racines grecques ou germanique
pour servir de langue internationale la
théologie aussi se développent et
charlemagne restaure la philosophie et
l'histoire
il fait aussi construire des cathédrales
dans tout l'empiré avec un art très
achevé de l'orfèvrerie des fresques et
des mosaïques inspiré de l'art byzantin
[Musique]
le portrait de charlemagne nous est
connue grâce à ea guinard son
contemporain grand il est dit qu'il
mesurait à mètre 92 il était fort et
vigoureux charlemagne inspire le respect
de ses ennemis qui sur le champ de
bataille craignent davantage sa force
physique que son intelligence tactique
d'une réelle beauté
il aimait faire des homos nos pauvres et
vénère sa mère qu'il consulte souvent
très attaché à sa famille
il ne se sépare jamais de ses enfants il
fut marié à quatre reprises
charlemagne à une grande curiosité
d'esprit il s'instruit beaucoup pour
pallier ces lacunes
il donna c'est une éducation complète à
ses enfants mais il est d'abord et avant
tout un guerrier bien que son but
affirmé soit la paix profondément
religieux il est convaincu que dieu a
confié au peuple francs et à son
souverain
la tâche de répandre est de défendre la
foi chrétienne ainsi que les coutumes
qu'elle a porté avec elle
il est souvent surnommé l'empereur à la
barbe fleurie en prêtant à l'empereur
une barbe alors qu'il était
vraisemblablement imberbe les
représentations du souverain veulent
souligner son autorité viril charlemagne
a cependant une épaisse moustache
charlemagne apprend à écrire tardivement
et ne parvient jamais à maîtriser cette
difficile technique ce qui le motive à
créer une école dans son palais afin que
les sommes devant le servir soit à même
de rédiger des rapports
cependant afin de lui permettre de
signer autrement que d'une simple croix
et gina lui apprend à tracer ce signe
simple un monogramme qui contient toutes
les lettres de son nom charles carolus
en latin les consonnes sont sur les
branches de la croix les voyelles
contenu dans le losange centrale bien
que ne sachant pas écrire charles man
c'est lire sa langue maternelle est le
francique il parle couramment le latin
et le grec
la figure de charlemagne est idéalisé
dans la culture médiévale notamment au
travers des chansons de geste avant sa
mort suivant la coutume franck
charlemagne prépare le partage de son
empire entre ses fils sans désigné de
successeur au titre d'empereur qu'est-ce
qui va sauver l'emplir un qui me rend
810 un qui meurt en rhuys anges et il ne
reste plus à ce moment là qu'un seul
fils chez louis celui qui était roi
d'aquitaine il le nomme co empereur en
septembre 813 à aix la chapelle
charlemagne décède le 28 janvier 814 à
aix la chapelle en 11 165 à
l'instigation de l'empereur frédéric
barberousse charlemagne émis au nombre
des saints par l'antipape pascal 3
cependant cette canonisation n'a jamais
été légitimée par la suite
peut être en raison de la conversion des
saxons par la force il ne compte donc
pas au nombre des saints mais son
culture est toléré et ça fait est fixée
au 28 janvier
son ep joyeuse et ses éperons d'or était
utilisée lors du couronnement des rois
de france
napoléon 1er utilisa lui aussi l'épée
joyeuse lors de son couronnement
impérial le fils de pépin le bref qui
donnera son propre nom à la dynastie
fondée par son père aura régné quarante
six ans durant lesquels son appétit de
conquête lui aura permis de soumettre
lombard saxe avare et bavarois
il y aura conquis la quasi totalité du
continent européen occidental
cet immense territoire où vivaient des
peuples aux cultures hétérogènes ne
pouvait se fondre en son royaume
il en fit un empire érigeant le
christianisme religion commune il
utilise à l'église comme un outil de
cette unification mais en fut également
un fidèle serviteur est le protecteur du
souverain pontife
organiser un si grand empire à une
époque où les moyens et les voies de
communication étaient très peu développé
et est un véritable défi auquel
charlemagne fit face avec habileté ils
répandent l usage de la money argent
pour mieux contrôler les échanges
il nomma des missi dominici dans chaque
comté afin d'améliorer la centralisation
de l'information et donc le contrôle des
territoires les plus éloignés il fit
venir en son palais des lettrés d'orient
et d'occident
lemmy la culture au service de son
pouvoir et de la religion qui devint le
ciment indispensable à la cohérence de
cet empire chrétiens d'occident mais
cette cohérence reposait également sur
la personne de l'empereur et ce dernier
ne crut pas que son oeuvre puisse lui
survivre il organise à son partage qui
sera le prélude de son éclatement
néanmoins on reconnaît en charlemagne le
pater européen le père qui forgea le
premier ensemble européen unis il y à
xii siècle
[Musique]